Very few people would enjoy getting eaten
by a bear in the woods.
That would undeniably be an extremely unpleasant
thing to happen to anyone.
Heck, it’s certainly enough to put a damper
on an otherwise fun weekend of camping.
But the one consolation of undergoing such
a tragedy is that you at least know nature
is taking its course.
After all, bears live in the woods, and if
you decide to enter their turf, there’s
an unwritten agreement that you’ll just
accept the consequences if a bear decides
it doesn’t want your company.
It’s another thing entirely if a bear eats
you in your bedroom, in the middle of suburbia,
miles away from any nearby forest.
That’s the unfortunate fate that befell
little Tommy Ellis.
His parents heard the bellowing roar of a
bear upstairs, the floorboards creaking under
its sudden weight.
What was happening up there?
They ran upstairs, following the sounds of
the roars and Tommy’s horrible screams.
But by the time they reached the bedroom,
it was already too late: The room was empty,
torn apart from within, as a six hundred pound
grizzly bear crawled its way out of the destroyed
bedroom window.
Tommy Ellis was never seen again…
To Tommy’s parents, before they were given
Amnestic treatment by agents of the SCP Foundation,
it was a freakish one-off tragedy.
But to those very same Foundation agents,
it was just another instance in a series of
deaths so strange and random that only some
kind of anomalous serial killer could be behind
it.
Two months earlier in a nearby town, a family
had undergone a savage attack from a full-sized
male silverback gorilla.
The huge and heavily territorial animal tore
the house apart, and beat anyone who tried
to stop it into a pulp.
Much like a bear attack, being killed by an
aggressive gorilla in the wild isn’t that
strange - but being murdered by a gorilla
in the suburbs of Cincinnati is definitely
a cause for Foundation intervention.
However, the gorilla killer was long gone
before any Foundation agents were able to
intervene.
At first, it was assumed that they were dealing
with some kind of animal SCP, but as more
grisly murders occurred, it began to paint
a better picture of what exactly was happening
here.
Next, a family was found dead after what seemed
to be a brutal attack with an edged weapon
- but this was no mere knife; all evidence
pointed to the weapon being a sword.
Neighbors interviewed by the Foundation about
the attack before their amnestic treatment
reported hearing a frightening ruckus coming
from the house next door, including a deep,
male voice saying, “I HAVE THE POWER!”
Much like He-Man, from the popular toy and
animation franchise.
This reminded them of another recent murder
case where the killer also reportedly used
a sword - though this time more likely a Japanese
Katana than a European Broadsword - and was
heard yelling “Cowabunga!” as they left
the scene.
As the bodies racked up, the evidence kept
piling on.
A young girl was traumatized by a naked man
suddenly appearing in her bedroom.
This would be horrible enough, but there were
a few strange details: He was handsome, athletic,
had bright blond hair, and no genitals.
In fact, he matched the exact description
of a child’s Ken doll.
And the thing that finally tied this whole
bizarre case together was an entire family
who were found to have been killed by electrocution
- despite all being in different rooms of
the house at their time of death, and showing
no evidence of having been moved post-mortem.
But the family’s youngest, Steven, had a
number of Pokemon cards
and action figures in his room, prominently
featuring the franchise’s most well-known
creature: Pikachu.
This shapeshifting, rampaging killer was caught
not long afterward when a full-sized pony
suddenly manifested in the home of another
suburban family - thankfully causing no fatalities
this time - and galloped off into the woods.
Seeing as the Foundation was already keeping
a close watch on the area to make sure they
caught any more strange activity, they were
able to quickly engage with and capture this
strange entity.
It was then sedated and sent back into containment
at the iconic Site-19.
The creature is now known as SCP-137.
So, you’re probably wondering: What exactly
is happening here?
What are the anomalous traits of SCP-137,
that appear to express themselves in such
random and violent ways?
While it may seem that 137’s abilities are
as diverse as they are dangerous, it actually
only has one, very simple anomalous power.
It possesses the toys of children and transforms
them into their real-life equivalent.
A teddy bear became an actual bear, a stuffed
gorilla became an actual gorilla, toys of
He-Man and a member of the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles became murderous sword-wielders,
and Pikachu became a wild animal with powerful
electrical abilities.
The SCP doesn’t appear to be inherently
violent, either.
Its level of aggression appears to be in the
eye of the beholder, as the attributes of
the toys possessed by SCP-137 are defined
by what a child perceives about said toy.
For example, a pretend gun becomes a real
one, capable of firing real bullets.
Toys of dangerous animals become equally deadly
in their real SCP-137 counterpart.
Warriors and soldiers become powerful killing
machines.
However, this works both ways.
Adorable or harmless characters remain equally
adorable and harmless when SCP-137 possesses
them.
It seems as though the entity that possesses
these toys doesn’t even have a consciousness
- it only takes up the mental attributes of
its hosts.
Incidentally, this was actually a crucial
factor in devising the proper containment
method for SCP-137 within Site-19.
Through testing, the Foundation discovered
that SCP-137’s anomalous range is at least
250 meters, with a possible upper limit of
500 meters.
In order to keep the creature in a consistent
and harmless form, the Foundation forbids
any unauthorized toy from being placed within
the 500-meter radius of SCP-137.
Essentially, the Foundation has boxed SCP-137
into a corner, meaning that any toy placed
within its anomalous proximity is its only
option.
In this case, the Foundation has locked SCP-137
into the form of a wholesome princess doll,
identifying itself as Princess Blossom.
When asked about its identity in this form,
the creature seems to have no awareness whatsoever
of its anomalous nature.
SCP-137 truly believes it is Princess Blossom
while occupying this form, repeatedly asking
interviewing researchers whether they’re
her prince, finally coming to save her from
this prison.
Sadly for 137, her prince will never come,
but perhaps she’ll spend every day looking
at her own cell door and hoping, being physically
incapable of knowing any better.
But of course, you’re not here to engage
with the heady existential realities of a
shape and personality-shifting anomaly.
Like any reasonable person in this situation,
of course, you want to hear about the experiment
logs, and find out just how far this entity’s
ability to anomalously take the forms of living
toys can stretch.
And don’t worry, we won’t disappoint you
on that one, either: SCP-137 has some of the
most insane testing logs we’ve ever seen,
and we’re going to share them with you right
now.
The last one especially is a real doozy.
First, overeager researchers made the terrible
decision to introduce a toy plane into the
testing chamber with SCP-137.
How could this possibly go wrong, right?
Well, here’s how: The toy plane was possessed
by SCP-137, which transformed it into a full-sized
F16 jet.
This jet then attempted to fly off while inside
the testing chamber, resulting in it flying
into the side of the chamber and exploding,
causing a massive amount of damage to Foundation
property.
Whenever one of SCP-137’s toy hosts is destroyed,
it returns to being a toy.
In this case, after the smoke cleared, a small
cluster of broken plastic was laying on the
floor.
The researchers were then forbidden from testing
any toys with jet engines or missiles.
But, they didn’t tell them anything about
toy race cars.
It seemed these researchers really were children
at heart.
They were amazed when the toy car turned into
a full-sized Ferrari, then plowed into the
wall at high speeds, exploding.
Vehicle tests were suspended after this.
The next test was actually kind of an accident.
An attending agent had an amusing little keyring
shaped like an alligator when entering the
250-meter range of SCP-137.
You can probably guess what happened next:
Because the keyring was technically close
enough to a toy, SCP-137 took it over and
transformed it into a six-meter-long saltwater
crocodile.
It then lashed out, attacking and devouring
nearby researchers.
Fourteen were dead by the time Foundation
Security Officers managed to safely enter
the scene and terminate the crocodile.
At that point, searches were intensified for
all personnel intending on working in SCP-137’s
500-meter danger zone.
Next, an action figure of an American Soldier,
complete with a toy rifle.
What do you think happened next?
If you guessed that this toy became a violent,
full-sized soldier that then went on to murder
a number of Foundation employees before being
taken out by several Foundation agents, then
you can take any prize from the middle shelf...just
make sure you don’t bring your prize too
close to SCP-137, or disaster could strike
again.
After this, a toy police officer was possessed
by SCP-137.
He began searching the testing facility for
“perps”, and encouraging the researchers
to stay away from drugs.
This seemed almost charming, to begin with,
until he pulled out his gun and murdered two
researchers, claiming they were criminals.
He handcuffed a third before finally being
terminated by Foundation Security Officers.
After this, researchers on the SCP-137 project
decided to veer away from testing on violent
or dangerous toys, and instead brought in
a stuffed panda - the sweetest and cuddliest
of all bears.
Everyone agreed that this would be a pleasant
change when SCP-137 transformed into one of
the big, adorable beasts.
One researcher, overjoyed at the presence
of the panda, accepted a hug from it.
The panda hugged far harder than anticipated,
breaking three of the researcher’s ribs.
It was terminated by Foundation Security Officers
soon afterward.
It turned out that the anomalous effects of
SCP-137 also applied to non-sentient toys.
For example, a box filled with lego blocks
became real terracotta bricks and construction
materials, and a yo-yo - even when placed
on a hook on the wall with nobody nearby - continued
to perform sick yo-yo tricks with reckless
abandon.
The penultimate test performed on SCP-137
involved an action figure of a character known
as Doctor Selenium, advertised as “The Smartest
Man on Earth.”
However, when SCP-137 transformed this into
a real-life Doctor Selenium, the Foundation
discovered that SCP-137 couldn’t actually
imitate more ephemeral qualities like incredible
intelligence.
This Doctor Selenium clone simply walked around,
constantly talking about how intelligent he
was rather than actually demonstrating that
intelligence.
He was probably the kind of guy who comments
“first” on YouTube videos.
And finally, the strangest test of all.
The Foundation constantly needs to worry about
moles and double-crossers in their midst.
They have tests to figure out the presence
of double-agents working for Groups of Interest
like the Chaos Insurgency or the Serpent’s
Hand.
But one group they didn’t have tests for
were Bronies, adult male fans of the cartoon
My Little Pony, based on the popular toy series.
And it just so happened that one of the researchers
on the SCP-137 case was indeed a Brony.
That’s why he snuck a doll of the purple
pony, Twilight Sparkle, into the testing chamber,
causing SCP-137 to possess it and turn it
into the real thing.
He engaged in a somewhat flirtatious conversation
with the talking pony, leading to the pony
offering to take the researcher back to her
castle so they could hang out.
After this testing session ended, the researcher
was removed from the project and then reprimanded
by his superiors for using an anomaly to fulfill
his personal interests.
But working at the Foundation is an incredibly
hard job, with the risk of death lurking around
every corner.
So who can really blame the guy for wanting
to hang out with his favorite cartoon character
between sessions with 096 and 682?
Which toy would you like SCP-137 to possess
and transform into a real-life counterpart?
Let us know in the comments below!
Then go check out “ALL the Little Misters
Explained” and “SCP-136 - Naked Doll”
for more terrifying anomalous toys!